mes chers collègues je vous demande de
bien vouloir regagner vos places la
séance est reprise voici le résultat du
scrutin majorité requise pour l'adoption
de la motion de censure sur la majorité
absolue des membres composant
l'assemblée 289 pour l'adoption 90 la
majorité requise n'étant pas atteinte la
motion de censure n'est pas adoptée je
vais maintenant mettre voir la motion de
censure déposée par Madame Mathilde
panot et 74 membres de l'Assemblée le
scrutin est annoncé dans l'enceinte de
l'Assemblée je rappelle que seuls les
députés favorables à la motion de
censure participe au scrutin avec le
vote se déroule dans les salles voisines
de l'hémicycle le scrutin va donc être
ouvert pour une durée de 30 minutes il
sera donc clos à 18h05 nous allons
pouvoir reprendre nos travaux
donc voici le résultat du scrutin
majorité requise pour l'adoption de la
motion de censure sur la majorité
absolue des membres composant
l'assemblée 289 pour l'adoption 218 la
majorité requise n'étant pas atteinte la
motion de censure n'est pas adoptée donc
aucune des deux motions de censure
déposées n'ayant été adoptées la
quatrième partie et l'ensemble du projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2023 sont considérés comme
adoptés